c'est ce que je trouve sur 10 défini
triplé without limite 3.0 star wars
édition voilà le nom du jeu le plus long
du monde
moi je m'en tiens aux dames et envoyé à
600 autres figurines qu'il soit là c'est
parti aujourd'hui on va faire un peu de
mode histoire et ensuite on va jouer un
mode que j'apprécie particulièrement
voilà je laisse un suspense 1 je réalise
des films aussi voilà avec un suspense
incroyable inception c'est moi il ya
bien longtemps dans une galaxie
lointaine très lointaine
rise again jean-pierre seynois
actuellement de l'avant turcs ont fait
un pas confondre avec rage against the
machine a été terrible dans la variable
de lutte le contrôle de magnifiques
intergalactique comme léon dalle est
heureux mais la volée les pleines de
larmes ultime de l'âme pire j'adorais
qu'est cette voie en même temps pendant
cette cinématique jouons avec les
figurines keep you annonce apic tient
sabres là comme ça sur la trouille aux
mondiaux on est dans l'espace en train
de jouer aux mondiaux monde devrait se
crasher matelas jetés sur la planète
sa sé nou là dedans ben là à balayer ce
que de la pure émoussé du coup on va
jouer chewbacca ah ouais c'est comme ça
que j'habite chaud c'est désastreux
alors c'est parti alors casse tout ça
give me xp please say you very much à ce
fameux cri on va les chercher on va les
chercher on arrive
j'arrive c3po j'arrive j'arrive juin
jusqu'à ces tout ça et je suis là c'est
quoi ça c'est quoi ça mais tu veux
qu'elle me dire avec toi mon gars est
chaude et schott a laissé des gages à
plus dans le bus il a pu faire le beau
affreusement olhao mais je vais vous
défoncer vous tout cela tient au late
show tafer méga balmont gars allez on
les fait jong un regard des oblats
jonglage des gages au hall à la nature
aime pas d'atterrir le non respect bonne
jouera je suis le même maîtres qui
faisait le générique qui a buté ces avis
bienvenue à mme on essaye voilà je dis
ce nom totalement mal ce que je peux le
shooter n'ont pas rejoint je voulais
prendre
attendez c'est génial vous les envoyez
vraiment voilà la violence bogeys ratant
veut prendre sa mecque aux surcharges
moi je veux tout mumbai stake très bien
donc actuellement deux vaisseaux est là
mais on peut pas le récupérer parce
qu'on a une grosse dette envers jab a eu
ce gros va faire la quête de ce mec ça
te dirait de faire la course bien sûr
bien sûr vers la cour si on peut gagner
des crédits grâce à ça tu crois que tu
peux battre le chrono de hann
je vais le battre ici allez on y va
l faut battre le chrono bonjour je
trahis hard geste et infiniti aa c'est
la course la plus facile que j'ai fait
de ma vie
et voilà allégués vie malgache que j'ai
pu faire mon vaisseau et je me tiens au
net l'argent l'argent que j'ai gagné
combien 200 crie-t-il c'est pas mal et
vous par contre mais cas c'est nous tout
est paré vous vous êtes moche êtes nuls
bla bla bla 360 et attend du coup on
peut au moins avant une coupe et en
voici le diagramme des compétences
voici le diagramme des compétences ça tu
peux acheter des compétences et pas de
l'argent là-dedans trois crédits dans
une caisse va falloir que d'en pêtre des
caisses
écoutez je pense qu'on écrase tout le
monde sur cette planète ait compris toi
surtout toi d'ailleurs bien là tiens at
on assure un max de crédit comme ça mon
gars ont en tout cas sans règle moi toi
wang est cet homme en quête et mis les
pieds qui bloque le palais de mon maître
on y va tout de suite on doit tout de
suite tour 1 c'est parti
poussez-vous niveau on y va on y va on y
va on y va c'est des méchants mais on va
les défenseurs regarde moi ça ça dégage
ça fait un méchant bad cops en l'air et
hurlaient john bradshaw bla bla génial
j'adore chewbacca tchoubaïs quasi
inverse nos scoops up de scoop ne
sauvegarder nos scoops attention mlg mlg
pro au pelage ongles
c'est fini c'est fini merci à tous au
max d'argent on est riche 12
regardez même le chat est content il
attend ses salades ou les animaux pète
quoi est ce que ça veut dire est pas de
faire un petit peu de cartes et ouais je
place cela sur le portail on n'est pas
alors on est donc dans la toy boy
speedway et voilà donc maintenant de
faire du kart sénoufo avec tous les
persos disney starwars c'est trop bien
direction non et non web non web voilà
comment on fait un départ turbo allez
les mecs sont tout soit ok ça soit qu on
est en pro en face on dans ce genre de
jeu tu comptais premier ça veut rien
dire tu peux te faire rattraper en 2de
un petit dérapage ne dira pas je vais
râpage qu'on apprécie mais j'ai déjà
rattrapé hier soir couvrant 40 monga
quoi
déjà c'est pas homologué déjà pour la
route 7 ce véhicule est le virage un peu
serré
à baho jadis nos champs du disney un
dernier tour c'est la cour au ventre
vers toi gros tu sais groot je voudrais
gagner cette coupe est devant le
carrossé croûte
on est d'abord tu as peur bondit
première des premiers premier le talent
maintenant on va mais au style ou pas
chauffeur chauffeur super champion voilà
j'ai encore raté au revoir sas a dit m
ça qu'est ce que j'ai à ça fuse
d'exister au bo facile non non non on
est dernier dark tu peux te calmer
comique est au clash tu sais que tu es
au fond du trou mais c'est vrai où vas
tu essayes c'est la fin à lecce les gars
je vous rattrapez vous n'êtes pas très
fort excusez moi pardon laissez-passer
dark ale tuant tout le monde à bientôt
arriver tout le monde s'inquiète plage
cela fait tout de suite cette fois on va
prendre le meilleur héros de star wars
impressionnant olaf au compte sur toi
mon gars r2 écrase de champion mais
quand ok j'ai pas réussi voilà les et
allez-y les gars gardez bien je suis
dans le rétro là on fait de figure
regardez regardez le lui totalement
ratée au attendait comme dirait mika qui
s'y frotte s'y pique
d'accord j'ai carrément doublé voilà la
vallée morte au revoir qui on est chaud
là olaf aux platines
olaf à la prod au la folie c'est à dire
ça or comme tout haut
attention les mains ah bah on l'aura
bien vide à 40 ans ou alors les gens se
dire pas de cette vidéo sur disney une
fille ni triplé without timide 3.0 star
wars of god et juste et définitive 3.0
mais j'aime bien cette volte face à nous
à puce c'est le cas n'hésitez pas aimé
la vidéo comme d'habitude à écouter la
première fois qu'on voit un super star
wars carte
voilà ça fait plaisir un super disney
cars d'ailleurs parce que c'est pas que
les persos de savoir si tous les persos
écoutez on s'entend très bientôt dans
une prochaine vidéo j'ai au titre pasqua
sur son bureau j'ai jeté chewbacca et
dark vador et ça a donné aux vieilles
dark vador est tombé qui s'est rattrapé
sur ce qu'elle est sans lui c'est à dire
des fêtes le chewbacca quoi tu me dire
merci pour ton intervention dark vador
récemment regardez la vidéo sur tous
deux prochaines journées